good morning believe nation today's
message is take risks over to you Wiz
Khalifa my crowd and everybody that I
talked to today they either dress weird
smoke weed you know Drive certain cars
escape and it's like I've done all of
these things and I've been into all
these things and I've learned them in
different stages of my life and it's
just an I'm in that stage right now I
was like I really want to do something
physical I got a son on the way you know
what I'm saying and learning how to
skate is like something I always wanted
to do but with rapping and making money
and providing for a family and stuff
like that you always get the time to
just grab a board and go skate so I kind
of did it in Reverse but there's
something I'm really passionate about
and just it's just passionate about
having fun with it I don't want to be
the best skater in the world I just want
to look like [ __ ] you know be able to
relax and cruise no judging from the
pictures you're also not afraid to take
a fall - yeah you can't be you can't be
man you're gonna take some Falls that I
hit my chin that's cool now like so am i
and like being that I'm on TV and I
perform everybody's like don't do this
you want to get hurt you won't get that
but you know you got everything is a
risk you know what I'm saying so if
you're not willing to take the risk then
there's no point doing it anyway I think
this is what happens to a lot of people
I think you come up with an idea for
something that you want to change right
you want to change your career you want
to study something else you want to
start a business you want to become a
dancer you want to become a rapper or a
skateboarder whatever it is you have
this new dream that you have that you're
not currently doing and you tell your
friends and you tell your people about
what it is and the natural reaction for
most of those people is they're gonna
point out all the reasons why that thing
is not gonna work right you didn't go to
school for that you're not smart enough
for that your parents don't have the
connections for that you've never done
that before all the reasons why it's not
gonna work out where very few people in
your life will be the champions very few
people in most people's lives are those
champions
who may help you find the shortcomings
but they'll help you get through them
and they'll give you the encouragement
and belief in yourself that you can do
it and so first of all you know if
somebody's only trashing your ideas you
want to be rounding those people right
like limit the exposure to those people
that may be your parents right great I
love you mom and dad but maybe you don't
share your next great idea with them of
all they're gonna do is trash it and say
how you're not worthy you're not able to
do it and then to just take the risk but
start small I'm not the guy who goes
all-in on something I want to test it I
want to test it in a small scale prove
it to myself that it works because if
you go out and you take out a huge
mortgage on your house or a huge debt or
whatever it is you borrow a ton of money
you think may not work
you've never tested it before so start
small a lot of people they think that
they they're starting here and they have
to just jump here they've got to go
all-in or it's not gonna work out and
because they don't raise the capital and
they can't take that big step then they
do nothing rather they just stick down
here constantly dreaming about that idea
they had and being frustrated that they
don't have whatever resource they've
convinced themselves that they need to
really get there where the reality is
you just got to start minimize the risk
but take that first step right take that
first risk and the thing that makes it
easier is it's not some big fatal risk
like if it doesn't work out you don't
lose your house if it doesn't work out
you don't owe your your aunt you know
$100,000 or whatever it is take that big
vision that you have tell the people who
are your champions and then stop talking
and start doing something about it find
the smallest possible way to get started
today do it tomorrow do it again
tomorrow do it again keep building
momentum for your idea and pretty soon
those small steps will turn into a much
bigger step and a much bigger step and
every step along the way you're
minimizing your risk so that you're not
going all in on something until you've
proven to yourself that it works so the
question today today is I'm curious what
is the thing that is risky in your head
that you're holding back from doing
right now in your business or your life
leave it in the comments below I'm super
curious we're gonna join in the
discussion thank you guys so much
watching have an amazing day I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot event special